رغم استقطال القوات الاوكرانيه في الحصول
على دبابات غربيه لصد هجوم من روسيا كبير
محتمل الا ان نجاح القتال البري لا يعتمد
على الدبابات وحدها بل مدى جوده تكامل
الدبابات مع بقيه المعدات وفقه
فمركبات مشاه القتاليه وفق الصحيفه اهم من
الدبابات بالنسبه لاوكرانيا واكثر الحاحا
هذه المركبات اخف تسليحا من الدبابات
ومصممه طبعا للتقدم مع الدبابات الثقيله
في المعارك لحمايتها من العدو وهنا
الولايات المتحده اعلنت في يناير الماضي
تزويد كياف المدرعات تسمى باسم برادلي
والتي يمكنها ان توفر غطاء للجنود
الاوكرانيين
ومركبه برادلي طبعا كما هو معلوم هي اسرع
من الدبابات القتاليه وادخلت للخدمه عام
وتمتلك واشنطن اسطولا منها بالالف هنا
خبراء عسكريون اوضحوا بان منورات الاسلحه
المشتركه بالدبابات والمركبات القتاليه
تساعد باختراق خط المواجهه الروسيه وتقليل
الاحتياجات الاوكرانيه لذخيره المدفعيه
وطبعا تقدير الخسائر
[موسيقى]